[Música]
buenas tardes hoy voy a hablar sobre la
meritocracia y voy a expresar mi
desconfianza a este concepto que impera
en nuestro sentido común
la meritocracia hace referencia habrán
escuchado el término a la cultura del
esfuerzo pero qué es la cultura del
esfuerzo
la cultura del esfuerzo es una
concepción que valoriza las capacidades
y los méritos individuales pero se
desliga de todo absolutamente de todo
contexto ocultando así la desigualdad la
falta de oportunidades y la injusticia
social
yo les quiero expresar esta duda al
término de meritocracia y quiero que
analicemos algunas cuestiones y
adjetivaciones que conlleva inherentes a
su uso la meritocracia en muchas cosas
es discriminatoria es racista es
supremacista es clasista es homofóbica y
es transfóbica pero además la
meritocracia es jugar a ser dios es
jugar a ser un juez supremo
el juez que determina lo que está bien y
lo que está mal
la meritocracia se pone en un pedestal
para de allí jugar a quien no se ajusta
a como ella quiere que sea
y desde allá arriba desde esa posición
de privilegio determina quién hizo
méritos y quién no lo hizo
así de fácil y sta es
pero lo llamativo es que lo determina
sobre realidades que no conocen y sobre
personas con las que jamás hablo
la meritocracia opina con liviandad y
prejuicio incluso sobre los deseos
por ejemplo con la tristemente famosa
frase son pobres porque quieren
así me pregunto yo con qué garantía y
legitimidad habla sobre situaciones que
no atravesó y sobre vidas que no vivió
yo a la meritocracia le pediría hacer el
ejercicio de compararse el ejercicio de
razonar
el ejercicio de sentir
el ejercicio de empatizar
y digo el ejercicio porque está claro
que no lo vivió no lo sufrió y no lo
lloró
como yo por ejemplo que por suerte y no
por mérito alguno
tampoco sufrir la exclusión la pobreza y
el hambre
pero haber nacido con estos derechos no
me enfrenta a quienes no lo estuvieron
al contrario me incentiva a luchar por
la igualdad de oportunidades
porque cuando veo al pibe de 10 años
limpiando vidrios en la esquina de mi
casa
pienso y viajo a cuando yo tenía esa
edad
viajo en mi mente y una vez haya
recuerdo
recuerdo que iba a la escuela
y va a practicar fútbol
inglés
al cine algún espectáculo
que comía todos los días y claro que
tenía tiempo para jugar
para jugar y aprender para jugar y
crecer para jugar y sociabilizar
y este chico no tuvo nada de eso y no
sólo él sino millones
tuvo que trabajar de niño pasar frío
calor tuvo que mojarse sufrir
discriminación violencia pobreza y
hambre como les digo en muchas
oportunidades no comer
y quiero repetirlo para naturalizar lo
no comer
intenten por un momento imaginar a las
niñas ya los niños cercanos en su vida
en esta situación
como pretende entonces la meritocracia
que un chico que crees en esas
condiciones
tenga las herramientas necesarias
para encarar este mundo
y peor aún
como pretende afirmar que ese chico es y
va a ser pobre porque quiere
todo esto me lleva a derribar otra frase
asociada a la meritocracia que es a mí
no me regalaron nada
yo esta frase la niego la critico me
opongo
me opongo porque si me regalaron
si me regalaron o al menos nací
con todos esos derechos
me tocaron si se quiere pero no hice
esfuerzo alguno por tenerlos como el
chico que limpia vidrios tampoco eligió
no tenerlos
ahora voy a dar otro ejemplo teniendo en
cuenta que aquí hay muchos estudiantes
soy un joven de un pueblo del interior
que quiere estudiar astronomía
es mi sueño y el de mi familia pero
ellos no me pueden sostener los estudios
y la vida aquí en córdoba por lo que
para cumplirlo debo trabajar
y comienzo a hacerlo
además
mis compañeros cuentan con una base de
inglés que yo no tengo y también
comienzo estudiar
estoy haciendo todo lo que está a mi
alcance para cumplir lo que tanto deseo
y un día
nos informan que la nasa otorgará una
beca a un estudiante de esta facultad
para lo cual hay que presentar proyectos
entonces a la vez que estudio
que trabajó y que estudió inglés
también me esfuerzo en preparar un
proyecto para cautivar a los veedores
después de la expectativa finalmente no
soy seleccionado
con este simple ejemplo
quiero que analicemos y pensemos
realmente alguien es capaz de decir que
no me forcé
que después de haber trabajado y
estudiado estudiado inglés y presentado
proyectos al mismo tiempo no voy a hacer
astronauta o no voy a hacer hoy voy a
estudiar en eeuu porque no hice los
méritos suficientes o peor aún porque no
quise
con estas dos situaciones queda claro
cómo trabaja la meritocracia en nuestros
discursos y lo deshumanizante qué es
pero a la vez deshumanizante tiene un
peligroso poder de penetración
este poder de penetración hace que
muchas veces muchos de nosotros
las asumamos y les repitamos sin
detenernos a pensar
en fin debemos entender que en esta vida
no todos arrancamos
de la misma línea de partida
y que muchas veces lo que determina
nuestra realidad es más ese punto de
largada que lo que podamos hacer en el
camino para cambiarla
porque está claro que no vivimos en un
contexto de igualdad de oportunidades
pero saben que a la meritocracia todo
eso no le importa
y con todo esto propongo que seamos más
comprensivos antes de criticar juzgar
o desmerecer
y que intentemos modificar nuestros
pensamientos nuestras concepciones y
nuestro sentido común de una forma para
que sea de una forma más abierta
y de esta forma también por qué no soñar
con construir una nueva sociedad más
justa más inclusiva y más igualitaria
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
pero